z-wave so nice to meet you i'm very good
with you i have to admit i was a little
nervous to interview you today oh my
goodness you are the third person to say
that to me what do you guys think that
i'm good i punched like guests in the
face no it's because i think you are
better at this job than me
no no no i'm excited to hear your
questions let's do it i love well how
does it feel to be the interviewee
i i
it feels exciting you know it's hard for
me to relinquish control but i think
that's a part of life
as a pisces
i can i can manage as a libra i would
like to share the wealth so we'll have
that
and even energy exchange
hi i'm z-way actress model pop star
last summer i went viral for asking
hard-hitting questions how many black
friends do you have
and now i famously have a tv show
starring me
[Music]
yo congrats on the success of the first
season it was so insane i mean you're so
brilliant and of course i've seen a
couple episodes of the second season but
i'm curious now that you have that first
one under your belt and guests more or
less know what they're in for did you
find that people were jumping at the
chance to be on the show or was it kind
of harder to book people this season no
it's easier it's honestly because we
don't have to explain it as this show
doesn't exist but this is the general
vibe here's a youtube clip now we have
andrew yang and friend leibowitz and now
even today we have chet hanks uh
charlemagne and all these great guests
like nicole buyer to show
um others that it's going it's a really
fun
loose interview that isn't about like
anything malicious it's just about like
having interesting conversations and
being vulnerable and honest and real
what kind of conversations did you want
to have like what were the big ones that
you wanted to address in season two i
mean every theme is
around what i really wanted to talk
about i'm obsessed with the like the
fanfare around critical race theory and
banning books i love that like i'm not
entirely sure people know what that
expression means and so that's that's
how i approach the charlemagne interview
versus celebrity rights activism you
know as a newfound celebrity i really
identify with people who who are you
know known and in public and so i wanted
to talk to someone who i would describe
as a famous baby on the show
this is an example of that as well as
climate change right we have this is
like one of the most prescient like
pressing issues of our lifetime why not
talk to elonic laser and then maybe
strip for the penguins to like raise
money against climate change but all of
this is great now that you're so famous
like what would you say is your favorite
thing about celebrity life and what's
the most challenging for you
um i can tell you that i spend a lot of
time just mostly sitting and typing
writing new jokes for the next six
episodes of the show that's what i do
with my time it's not numerous but it is
fun i love that well i can tell you have
so much fun on this show we have to talk
about one of your most iconic bookings
yet which for me was dumbois like
like what how
did you get to actually
meet the person behind dumois or was it
actually like their identity was hidden
from them no their identity was obscure
which i i i honestly love
that because to me okay so this is gonna
get a little heady but it's like
the people in charge of these like huge
companies are just like right like us
they could be anyone literally ed dumois
could be anyone you could be tomorrow
you know and so i think that having her
identity obscured and having her answer
questions like how many black friends do
you have a favorite george orwell book
that is
priceless like i love that interview
with doom wall i feel like you guys are
vibing i
i think that dubois is an icon and i
would love to chat with her again
yeah were there any requests that you
had for that interview or did you have
any requests for you or did it just
happen we have a pre-interview and we
briefed our guests so they they're aware
i mean and also the show has a season
one so they're aware that it's going to
be sort of like offbeat questions and a
little raucous and fun but that's kind
of the excitement around it right is
that you never know what to expect from
the from me as a host but also from the
guests and so when you when you're
surprised as an audience i'm also
surprised
honestly honestly like you are feeling
that moment as a community
honestly yeah oh so so that was that was
the process with her
are there any marginalized communities
you want to apologize to
no
another great guest chet hanks
i mean
i'm assuming it was your idea to have
him on but was he um i don't know did he
surprise you at all
i mean chet surprised me i was trying to
figure out how the interview came to be
i reached out to him like a year ago to
book him on my ig live and it never
worked out and then he ran him a guest
dropped out and then he randomly texted
me just like congratulating me on my
work and then i asked him like oh hey do
you want to do the show and then i
booked him and he flew in like two days
later so i was so delighted he had been
someone who i thought would be an iconic
guest for years and i think that
interview was an iconic interview it was
so wild i mean what did you think of him
like flirting with you during the
interview and just some of his isms like
he had some one-liners where i was like
okay chad
the i think my favorite part is the way
that the crew sort of turns against me
like there's nothing on video that could
capture the way in which that they they
sort of those benedict arnolds sort of
walked away from me and into the arms of
chad hanks and i that is
beyond it was like arsenio hall like
people were cheering his name it was
absolutely i couldn't have never
expected it because the interview was so
it was the different energy right like
him being like you guys are going to
clap and then by the end he's like doing
a diet tribe about the universe so i
think that that's kind of a testament to
the interview process right even with
friend last season you kind of loosen up
it's it's but it's as fun as fun as
you're having watching it the discomfort
and like the like laugh out loud moments
that's how we feel in person it's really
silly he somehow made quoting the joker
from the dark knight so endearing like
it was weird and all of a sudden he
didn't stop and it's like oh well he is
just living in it in the moment
my favorite part was when he goes um
john david washington
shout out to john david washington i
love it it's iconic and but what's nice
about this show is that like there's an
energy for everyone right so it's like
there's a conscious dominant have you
you haven't seen the katja episode the
picture episode is quotables oh
quotables and yeah of course katya is an
icon and so the every single interview
you're like if you if it has a general
vicinity of your interest you're going
to enjoy it like alana glazer we do if
you guys haven't seen that she we have
we bring out a child and we make her
apologize to a child about climate
change
and
it is
comedy gold so
if you're gonna believe it yeah
burst we talk about being a landlord
like nicole buyer in her 19 000 shows so
there's there it's a good time how did
you feel walking away from the
charlemagne episode because i you know
you really didn't hold back you know
bringing up his past at all it was i had
so much fun i think that's one of my
favorite interviews um it's hard to pick
a favorite interview but what i love
about that one is that charlemagne has
been in the public eye for decades
and so to find new quotes from him he's
written two books he's you know really
established and to have questions for
him that he's never been asked before
i thought that was really really fun and
exciting and i think that the audience
will feel the same way like it's
electric
it was that interview that made me
nervous because i'm like you are really
good you like to like you know you sit
in those moments and let them breathe
and then you also like are honest i
appreciate it i really do and i also
appreciate how in that first episode you
addressed the critics right of the first
season how do you think people will
react this season
oh good question i mean we'll have to
hear from my favorite podcaster who's to
say
[Music]